endoplasmic reticulum is a production
house of the cell now there are several
machineries which is folding the
proteins monitoring its quality so
quality control and production happening
simultaneously in the endoplasmic
reticulum once the proteins are properly
folded and its quality is monitored from
endoplasmic reticulum the protein can
move out to several locations inside the
cell first it goes to the warehouse the
Golgi apparatus and from there it is
spread out into different organelles or
it's secreted out now you have to
understand that inside the endoplasmic
reticulum
there are several two categories of
protein one protein which is going to be
delivered to the warehouse that means in
the Golgi and there are some proteins
which are the maintenance proteins which
are the proteins that are going to fold
the incoming proteins in the ER that
those are called your resident protein
you can think them as you can think
about them as a machines inside a
factory right now so definitely the
machines that are used in production
should not go to the warehouse right so
there should be stringent mechanism by
which they should not be packed at the
first place to move towards the
warehouse and second of all if there is
some mistake and due to chance it is
moving to the warehouse it should be
revert back and here comes a concept of
ER resident proteins now from the ear
lumen let's say during packaging of
every protein one particular ER resident
protein marked here in blue is
transported into trans-golgi network now
ear resident proteins has one unique tag
it consists of lysine aspartate
government and leucine known as ke dil
sequence and this Kadel sequence is
necessary and sufficient to hold the ear
resident proteins inside the ER so
scientists have designed experiment
where they have put cadence sequence
Genet
we put the Keadle sequence on to a
protein which is generally secreted out
and they found that this protein is
retained in the ER and not secreted and
also so what happens is whenever in the
year lumen along with some secretory
protein or protein distant to other
organelle when the year resident protein
is kind of MIS packed and delivered to
the trans-golgi network inside the cell
transcultural network there would now
there are Cadell receptors gated
receptors are specific to the K del
sequences on the ER resident protein now
Carol and Carol receptor can find each
other it turns out that KL can act Cadle
receptor can actually interact with the
caught one coat proteins and the cop one
coat proteins get assembled onto the
trans collagen membrane and pay like
take back the vesicles into the ER lumen
now inside the ER lumen the pH is very
different now in fact pH the KL
containing protein is dissociated from
the Cadell receptor and as a result the
yet resident protein is delivered back
to the year even if it is delivered
mistakenly to the trans-golgi network
this is how stringent quality control
protocols are maintained inside the cell
now it has been shown that in normal
situation the ER resident proteins are
bound to are mainly found in the
endoplasmic reticulum right but in case
of yeast mutants which are mutated for
cough one particle scope-1 alpha and
Kevon beta in that situation it has it
turns out that your resident proteins
are not retained inside the ER rather
than just recruited out so that is how
it also tells us that this retrograde
transport
from trans-golgi network to endoplasmic
reticulum also involves cost one I mean
there's this whole backward transport of
ER resident proteins involves cop one
mediated particular translation so what
we learned is there are interrogate
transport which might mistakenly take ER
resident proteins along with the
proteins that need to be delivered to
specific location towards the
trans-golgi network but inside the
trans-golgi network they are sorting out
mechanism which can sort out that ER
resident protein and send them back to
the endoplasmic reticulum by a
retrograde transport of